so am Oki other than to say that I was
aiming for the longest title and this
workshop oh let's go on to the to the
topic itself and they as you know weigh
in their spending and we know that that
recent human demography had a
substantial impact on patterns of
genetic variation specifically recently
a recent deep sequencing studies reveal
the huge amount of rare variants likely
the result of recent explosive growth
over the past day 5000 years or so and a
and the older studies and newer studies
as well and it revealed a substantial
excess of a of common variants in
Europeans and Asian's compared to
Africans likely the result of a
bottleneck or series of bottlenecks a at
the Out of Africa split and these a
dramatic effects on day on genetic
diversity naturally lead to many
questions a couple of these questions is
whether this change in in the attributes
of genetic variation affected the burden
of genetic disease or the genetic load
in human populations and perhaps it
should be different in different human
populations and the second question is
um how that may have affected the
architecture of a complex disease or
other other quantitative traits and
specifically you could think if for
example due to growth in a lot of the
risk of complex disease comes from a
rare rare variants that could help
explain and the missing heritability
that we see in many cue us as well as
they suggest some may that that we will
require strategies based on deep
sequencing in order to map a lot of the
underpinnings of a of genetic diseases
and for these reasons and others there's
been lots of speculation about
this topic recently there's been claims
that maybe the genetic load should be a
higher in non-africans compared to
Africans or vice-versa and maybe due to
recent growth there should be a major
some some a contribution of added
contribution of rare variants through
two-way disease risk um so I'll begin by
giving away the punchline of my talk
which is what we have found that that at
least our work suggests that the effects
of these demographic events on a genetic
load were probably quite minor if at all
and that the architecture the effects on
architecture strongly dependent how
strongly a trait or a disease is coupled
with a with Fitness so having given the
way the punchline will tell you a little
bit about how we reach these conclusions
and so what what we do in order to study
these questions we use a very standard a
bi allelic finally a viability selection
model with two-way mutation and well
I'll assume for just for simplicity that
the mutation rate to say equal in both
directions and we focus on the semi
dominant and recessive cases even though
we show that they're qualitative results
are similar across the range of
dominance coefficients and we assume a
linkage equilibrium and multiplicative a
fitness say across sites to make things
as simple as possible and then we look
at three demographic scenarios one is a
complex demographic scenario it recently
inferred by a Tennyson in co-authors for
african-americans including a recent
explosive growth and for a European
Americans including the Out of Africa
split two bottlenecks and recent growth
as well as migration between these two
populations and the main features the
important thing is the main features of
these day of this model are similar to
other recent models where the estimates
here were based on name or
beta M now in order to get better
understanding of the main demographic
effects then we also use two simple
models one is a bottleneck model using
the European parameters and another is a
growth exponential growth model using
the African parameters from this model M
so so first I'll begin with genetic load
and now you know as I'll remind you that
genetic load is defined as the relative
reduction in Fitness new to the
deleterious alleles and specifically we
focus on the genetic load at a given
site the expected genetic load at a
given site which means that given the
parameters for this site the dominance
coefficient and the selection
coefficients we could simulate or run
the many independent sites through the
demographic scenario and you get the
distribution of the material frequencies
and then we want to know what's the
expected load at the site given this
distribution and specifically this
expectation would simply be the
reduction in Fitness due to due to a
heterozygote times the expected number
of heterozygotes a plus the reduction in
the deleterious homozygous times the
expected frequency of the materials
homozygous and we we focus on the single
site and we note that at least with the
multiplicative fitness scheme then then
the load that many independent sites
would be a simple function of this say
of this load M now just as a another
reminder when we have a constant
population size the genetic load
exhibits three dynamic regimes a one is
the strong regime where essentially all
the deleterious alleles are segregating
at very low frequencies and for the semi
dominant case from the classic mutation
selection balance their calculations we
get that the load would be two times the
mutation rate
and for the recessive case it would be 1
times the mutation rate and then there's
the effectively neutral regime or by
effectively neutral I'm in that
selection is not doing anything to elude
allele frequencies and most of the load
in that case would come from a sites
fixed or the deleterious alleles and
because those don't change as we
increase the selection coefficient and
the load just increases linearly and
then you have the region in between the
weakly selected region and then the
beginning it increases linearly just
because of the increase in the selection
coefficient and then it starts
decreasing because of the decrease in
the frequency of the material appeals so
we have these three dynamic regimes mmm
so now I'll give you a sense of how our
results look like our simulation results
look like em so I'll first focus on the
simple simple case of growth and because
we're interested in changes of loads due
to a recent demography what we could do
is we could look at the difference in
loads in in our demographic scenario and
subtract the loads in a constant
population size and specifically the
constant population size before the
onset of the non-equilibrium
demographics and now you were
considering and and we look at that
across a range of their selection
coefficients I see you can't see this
very well but this goes from very weak
10 to the minus 7 to 10 to the minus 1
so we span the range the important line
here is the blue one which is the total
difference in load for the semi dominant
and recessive cases and if you look at
the y-axis you see that there's a
effectively a very small effect in this
case practically negligible effect
however we could also break the load up
to the contribution from segregating and
fixed sites and then you see that
actually in terms of the dynamics we
have the same three parameter regimes we
had before where this is the effectively
neutral weakly selected and a strongly
selected regime and now if we look at a
the other demographic scenarios I told
you that we looked at em that the
Tennyson complex model the bottom
model then we see that the important
thing here that is that in all cases the
the total difference in load that we see
is very very small even in the case
where it's the largest which corresponds
to the bottleneck recessive scenario
then the blue line is still very small
if you look at the AE x axis in this
case we actually have a fourth dynamic
regime but but this is the bottom line
but of course you know in order to a
better understand why this is the case
then what you need to do or at least
what we needed to do is to break this up
into the different cases and the
different dynamic regimes because the
explanation for what's going on here is
different different selection regimes
and dominance coefficients so just to
tell you they this is a in the paper or
more accurately in the supplement we go
through all these cases and we use
extensive simulations and analytic tools
in order to understand what's going on
in each of these regimes and and today
I'm just gonna try to give you a taste
of a of two of these regimes the first
one M is the strong selection dominant
case what happens what happens there
and so what what what I'll assume in
this case is a by dominant I mean that a
the dominant coefficient is sufficiently
large such that selection a AK say only
on heterozygotes okay and so so this
would be true for any dominance
coefficient which is sufficiently large
M and in this case to give you the
simple intuition let's look at the case
a case of constant and changing
population size so if we so in this case
I marked a by black just the total
number of alleles and in red I marked
the expected number of a deleterious
mutations that arose due to mutations
that the rows tell generations in the
past and what we see is that in a single
generation the expected number of
the latias alleles just is just reduced
by one minus HS due to selection on
heterozygotes now if we move to the case
where to a changing population size case
so specifically here for example I
assume the population grows by a factor
of 1 plus a every generation so you see
that the total number of alleles grows
then then and now you could look at the
expected change in the number of
deleterious alleles in this in a single
generation then the expected gain here
is gonna be a 1 minus HS due to
selection and heterozygous time 1 plus
AE due to the increase in population
size however if you look at the allele
frequency then the came due to the
increase in population size is precisely
balanced by the change in the total
number of alleles and you know you could
write it down formally and you could
show that for M for something that's a
sufficiently strongly selected and
sufficiently dominant this would be true
for an arbitrary change in population
size you expect no no difference in in
loads in
so you just recover the classic mutation
selection you need to go through the
branching process what you just recover
the classic mutation selection balance a
results for the deleterious allele
frequency and for the expected load m to
give you a little bit a more intuition
about what's going on it's useful to
think about you know where allelic
trajectories so let's consider a two
populations one larger than the other
and here I'm showing you just a mutation
that arises and goes through the
population in this cartoon until it goes
extinct so these are the numbers in now
because a the selection and because of
the selection and heterozygous is
sufficiently strong then we could assume
that the deleterious alleles in every
substantial population frequencies at at
any point which means that we could
approximate this very well by a
branching process another an implication
of this is that if you just look at the
trajectories of a single mutation in
numbers
they could look you know the same
statistically speaking in a smaller in
larger population the numbers just
follow the same process okay what will
happen in a larger population in this
case the blue one is you just have you
know more mutations arise okay but
however again if we look at the a
frequency of deleterious alleles then
because this red guy is in a smaller
population it's a frequency would be
larger so what happens is that the input
of a double tears alleles is balanced by
the increase in the population size and
from this you also see that actually the
properties of genetic variation will
change why the load will remain the same
because you see that you're gonna have
the larger population you'll have more
segregating sites but they're going to
be segregating at a lower frequency okay
and and this would also be true in for a
changing population size they say they
say basic inside the the last thing I'm
going to tell you about this say this
case of a strong selection and at least
partial dominance is is that while the
load remains the same and and the
property is a variation change em they
came very quickly in this case so so
here you see the bottleneck in in their
growth scenarios and we're looking at
various statistics of a of segregating
sites at numbers per million strongly
selected sites in this case with the
selection coefficient of 1 percent and
you see that the load which is in in
this case just the number proportional
to the number of deleterious alleles per
individual remains the same in all these
cases but if you look at other
statistics such as the number of
segregating sites or the fraction of
segregating sites that they're rare in
this case below 0.1% then these came
very quickly after the bottleneck or
after the onset of growth and the reason
they came very quickly is because of the
turnover of a strongly selected
allele through a population is very
quick so the trajectories behave like 1
over the selection course
and therefore very quickly you
equilibrate to the properties of the new
population size in the next case I'll
show you which is less interesting but
still I think we're worth looking at is
is a is the case of growth with a weak
selection M and in this case what we saw
from from the simulations is the mode
again as it has a very little effect
unload what you do see in the weakly
selected regime that the contribution
from fixed sites goes down and is
precisely compensated by the
contribution from segregating sites and
so what's going on here so if we
consider so the feature of the weak
selection regime is that you is that
many sites are fixed for the material
Salil and when when you think the a
population size at least at equilibrium
then if we look at the proportion of
sites fixture the deleterious alleles as
a function of the scale selection
coefficient to an S then it obviously
goes down very quickly in the weakly
selected regime so you would expect that
if you change the population size you're
gonna move around having more fix for
the deleterious allele to less fix
through the deleterious allele and of
course you'd be right the only problem
is that this process happens extremely
slowly because it's mutation limited so
here you see in the the same fraction of
sites as a function of time in a in
units of million generations for the
bottleneck and growth in scenario so it
just takes a very very long time because
you're waiting for the mutations to come
in to survive the initial period and
then fix and you have a long way to go
in and then you could wonder ok so this
is the so we don't see almost any change
in in fix then you could say ok maybe
we'll get the change from what
segregating in the population and so
here you see the the results of some of
the simulations for the
a constant population size and growth
case you see the frequency spectrum of a
deleterious alleles and focus so here
that you can see the gray very well but
but this is a logarithmic region and
besides that I'll talk about in a moment
but in any in intermediate frequencies
or most of the frequencies you see no
change at all and the reason again is
because they aim weakly selected
segregating sites take a very long time
to change their distribution and the
growth and humans was it was very very
recent compared to that time scale so so
practically you have no a no a notable
difference the one difference you do see
is if you focus very closely to the to
the boundaries of this frequency range
you see that you have a large increase
in the growth case in the number of
sites segregating with very very low
frequencies and the reason is you know
you increase the population size you
immediately increase them you take a
little input so mutations enter but they
don't have time to go anywhere and
that's why in a and okay so this is just
contrary to the strongly selected Chi
case weakly selected the sites take a
very long time to respond to the
demographic changes and and this effect
that the boundaries is exactly what
explains this shift from fixed load to
segregating load M so M so we go through
these cases and we see that there should
be it seems that there is there should
be very little effect on genetic load
and luckily we could we could check a
strongly related prediction so we could
take to human populations with very
dramatic differences in their
demographic history like an African in
European populations and a according to
our predictions individuals in these
populations more than average carry in
the same number the latias alleles and
that could be true if we look at
different classes of
it's M M so we we do that and we do that
using deep sequencing data from from
african-americans and european-americans
and also using the Central European and
Yoruba
data from the thousand genomes project
and then in order to classify so this is
exome data so in order to classify the
amino acid variants that we have in our
data set we could use a one of the tools
that exist to a to a classify variants
according to their degree of severity
like polyphen to use polythene to used
other a methods of a classification and
then once you have this data what you
could do is you could take a you know
equal size samples from both of the
populations and and then within each
class you look at all the variants that
segregate in the joint sample so
obviously what doesn't segregate the
joint sample won't would be the same in
the two populations the important but
but it's important to look at at the
joint sample and then what you could do
is at all the segregating sites you
could look at the average the average
derived allele frequencies in each of
these classes in each of these
populations so that's equivalent up to
multiplicative factor to the average
number carried by by a individual so we
do that and there's some nasty biases
that we had to go over which I won't go
into but but we're glad to tell you
about when you get to the questions and
this is what we see so here what you see
is that the mean derived allele a
frequency in different classes of sites
including non-coding synonymous benign
and synonymous possibly damaging and
probably damaging nonsynonymous a
variance where if you want the numbers
there they're down here now the the red
corresponds to the african-american
blue to the European Americans and the
widgets correspond to two standard
deviations around the meet em and and
you look at this and say you take the
synonymous as a proxy for neutrality so
that is reassuring to see that there is
the same because this just tells you
that you know effect say relating to
differences in mutation rate per per the
time of the lineage like Molly discussed
today are not are not a big factor
tomorrow yesterday we um so this is a
useful control and you also see that as
you go to a more severe class according
to the classification than indeed the
frequencies go down so the
classification is definitely doing what
it's supposed to do em but more
interestingly in our context there's
practically no difference between these
estimates okay none of them is even
remotely significant and that that
remains the case if you look at
different classification management
methods and I'll just note that huge
amounts of data went into these
estimates so it's not the result of
having very little data of course having
more would be good yeah the mean derived
allele frequency reduction think about
it as a you know up to what well if
sites are fixed day for one of you in
one population and another allele and
the other population they did would be
segregating in the joint sample and
therefore they would be counted here um
so okay so you so you could do this say
we see yeah absolutely because if you're
interested in the average number of
derived alleles carried in the two
populations if you wouldn't count that
then then that would be pretty bad right
because you could have a deal here Salil
in one and nothing the other and you
wouldn't count
so you want to come that when you're
considering the average number of the
materials carried by an individual so um
so none of the yeah yeah so if you're
thinking about the let's see mark here
so so if you're thinking about the about
the neutral site and we're looking at
the number of derived allele per
individual and assuming that generation
time and mutation is all the same then
you could think about it as a single
sample from one generation and a single
sample from the other degeneration and
and you're asking how many derived
alleles you're going to see here and
here and assuming all the standard
assumptions given that this lineage
these lineages are the same length you
expect the same the same number okay so
that's why you expect the the neutral
case to be the same so it's actually
reassuring it's kind of a control for
things like differences in mutation
rates affecting the some differences in
generation time and so on
so um okay so we're yeah so we do this
with using different data sets different
methods of classification and so on we
get essentially the same results um okay
so so far we've seen that at least the
particular theory and simulations it
should be the same and as far as the
data analysis said is it is the same as
far as we could tell given our data but
the fact that the law doesn't change
doesn't mean that the genetic
architecture of a disease risk or other
quantitative traits doesn't change
because we do we do see the K the the
property is a genetic diversity of F J
of polymorphisms changing a lot
specifically under growth the load
remained the same because we had an
increase in the number of segregating
sites counterbalanced by reduction and
frequency and in the case of bottlenecks
we had the opposite so this this
to ask him whether a recent population
growth for example they led to a greater
role of rare alleles in in disease risk
or other quantitative traits or
conversely did the Out of Africa
bottlenecks lead to where common alleles
contributing much more and non-africans
compared to Africans okay um and the
first step in in in addressing this is
to note that the answer to this question
usually depends on the selection acting
on the variants that you're considering
so what so what we could do is we could
in a you know way we could look at the
different selection coefficients in this
case we took a certain weak selection
coefficient in a strong one and we could
run things through the demographic model
and get a distribution of a very real
frequencies and then we could calculate
under the the simplifying assumption of
a of an additive model in both their
fitness and effect size we could
calculate the contribution of different
frequencies in to the various in the
trait and so here you see the
contribution of a of a alleles below a
certain minor allele frequency to the
variants in a trait with with two
selection coefficients and and if we
begin by looking at the strong selection
case and let's begin by looking at the
constant population size case then then
in that case in this is the line for the
constant population size case then what
we see is with strong selection then a
practically all the contribution to
variance comes from rare alleles in this
case below a frequency of one and a half
percent and okay and that's pretty clear
because they're strongly selected so
they don't get a very high frequencies
and now when we look at the lines for
African and European including the
recent growth then we see that the
variances could
by alleles with a much lower of the Olea
frequency and the reason for that is
that the the same strongly selected
alleles because their turnover is so
fast a lot of them arose after the onset
of growth and therefore you have more
segregating sites but segregating at
lower frequencies the case of therefore
you have this shift towards rares if
selection is very strong however if you
look at the weekly selected a case in
this case most of the variants would be
contributed by variants that reach high
population frequencies and and the onset
of growth did nothing effectively to the
frequencies of these a of these alleles
and therefore comparing the constant
population size to the African and
European we don't see any substantial
change in the contribution of rare
alleles the one thing we do see here is
in the in this green line corresponding
to Europeans as we see the effect of the
Out of Africa bottlenecks in the model
so due to the Out of Africa of
bottlenecks we have quite a
substantially larger contribution due to
common alleles actually in this case
okay him however and you know what
another thing we could do and I'm just
going to go through this quickly is we
could take our a class of probably
damaging variants and we could assume or
simplify modeling assumptions and throw
them all together and see what we would
get the zooming that they all contribute
to some trait and in this case we also
see it's much closer to the weakly
selected case so so they contribute they
need there is some amplification of
rares but it's it's relatively quite
quite minor and however a life so so
demography could have a substantial
effect this effect will depend on very
strongly on the selection acting on the
variants however in reality for a
quantitative trait we're going to have a
mixture of selection coefficients and
effect sizes so how should we think
about that
and to think about that first we can
think about two extremes so you could
think about one extreme where the
selection coefficient on the variant and
the effect size are essentially
independent so how that would happen so
it just means that our trait has very
little effect on Fitness but the
specific variant would have clear topic
fitness effects that just comes from how
it affects other phenotypes okay so
maybe examples for that are a somewhat
amorphic traits like height or maybe
late onset the disease or that you know
has little effect on fitness would be an
example of this a clear tropic extreme
and then you have the other extreme
where actually a trait we're looking at
is the is is what mediates the main
fitness effect of our variants so maybe
examples closer at least to this extreme
would be severe early onset diseases or
diseases that have very severe effect on
fertility so it's very likely that most
traits lie somewhere in between
perhaps most traits closer closer to
this and so just to understand how the
difference between the two M so how
would the contribution of rare and
common alleles will change within this
range let's take a very simple a toy
model so in in in this toy model I'm
assuming that mutations come in two
flavors there's mutations with a very
strong effect and mutations with a very
weak effect in but then for those with a
strong effect I assume that they have a
probability 1 plus P divided by 2 cans
to have a large effect size on the trait
were considering and otherwise they're
gonna have a small effect and for the
weakly selected mutations I'm going to
assume that with probability 1 plus P
over 2 they will have actually a small
effect on the tray
and otherwise a larger effect so so the
this is obviously a very simple model
but what you could see looking at this
model as if I assume that this P is
equal to zero then what's going to
happen is all the strong ones so if P is
equal to zero then the effect size is
going to be half large half small in
both of the cases so essentially you
don't have no correlation between
selection coefficient and effect size
and if P is equal to one then you'll
have a perfect correlation because the
strongly selected mutations will have a
large effect and vice versa and the
other case in more more generally a the
nice thing about this very simple model
is that the marginal distributions of
selection coefficients and effect sizes
actually do not depend on this P but the
correlation between selection
coefficient and effect size is precisely
P so it gives us a way of not changing
any of the margin or the solutions but
changing how strongly the trait is
coupled with Fitness M so we could use
this model and and you know again here
you know you could simulate it then you
could look at the contribution of rare
alleles in this case below where point 1
percent and to the variance in the trait
and we're first we'll look at the
constant population size and then at the
African and European cases and what you
see when you look at the constant
population size is that when the trait
is when the trait is it is not coupled
with Fitness and essentially most are
variance in the trait will come from
weakly selected things that wreak very
high population frequencies and just
happen to have a large effect size on
their traits ok that's where the
variance is going to come from and
therefore rare alleles and the strongly
selected morton's which are a subset of
the rares will have a very very little
contribution to variance and in in our
trait on the other end where most of the
variance is going to come from a most of
the variance is going to come from
alleles that have a large effect on our
trait in this case they are strongly
selected and they will therefore be rare
and therefore in the strongly selected
case we have a mark
largerr a substantial contribution from
may from rare alleles now let's think
what happens through the non-equilibrium
demographic scenario so so if if we have
a recent growth then obviously it's
gonna affect our strongly selected
alleles in throughout the range in the
same way but the contribution to
variance is only going to be affected
we're are strongly we're are strongly
selected alleles contribute
substantially to the variance to begin
with so what world's does it just
amplifies the contribution of strongly
selected and rare alleles in in the case
that the trait is strongly coupled with
Fitness now I'll just note in in closing
that a very similar argument suggests
that a if you consider cases where for a
trait that's more weakly coupled with
Fitness the Mende Out of Africa
bottlenecks would have would have a
large effect generating you know
increasing the contribution of common
alleles in non-africans compared to
Africans by a very similar argument so
to sum up our results suggest that the
Out of Africa bottleneck and a and
recent population growth had little
effect on the genetic load in our data
analysis a seems to be supportive of
this notion as for the architecture of
complex disease and other quantitative
traits then it seems that by and large
there's reason to believe that most
traits are closer to the our loosely
coupled with Fitness and closer to that
ended in that case we actually expect a
strongly selected sites and strongly
selected variants and rare variants to
contribute little and therefore growth
would have a little amplifying effect a
possible exception are traits that are
strongly coupled with fitness
and I didn't time time to show you but
it's exactly by the same arguments the
Out of Africa bottleneck would have a
kinda like the double opposite effect it
says that through traits that are
loosely coupled with Fitness will have a
large contribution of common alleles in
non-africans compared to Africans in so
to sum up by all they use the the the
version where there's pictures and at
the end and they and they they say that
it was a pleasure this work was a
collaboration between jonathan pictures
lab now at stanford formally in chicago
and in in my lab and a michael torchin
who's sitting right over there did the
the heavy lifting with the data analysis
and Yuval simmons from my lab did the
bulk of the simulation and there's some
theory on this and they should also
thank a David Rykken Camille sanaya for
many useful conversations about this a
bias and the site but Suffocation's and
other issues during this work so thank
you
the frequency I'm sorry I didn't hear
some questions over here
well I think it's a debauch sickness I
think this would actually give a it's
unclear to me I think they should you
know both about the same way it's an so
I thought we'd be behind they're
comparing it this way it's just this is
equivalent to just a counting up how
many they derived alleles which is a
proxy for the number of deleterious
alleles a in in individual and a given
population and and you want that
according to our results this should be
a very similar in each class but about I
think that therefore if we do what what
you're suggesting given that they're the
same across classes that we're going to
get it the same answer
yeah yeah I can't be you know because of
the statistically can be a hundred
percent sure but I would be surprised so
I take two things one is in in one is
that a we were focusing on you know
these European versus African a
parameters and you could imagine in the
founder populations that had a much more
severe bottleneck that you make it
slightly different yourself I don't
think that's the case in the paper
you're talking about
i I think that you know among other
among other things in that paper I think
for example they don't account for so
when we did this data analysis what day
what happened and they in parallel that
happens in the in David Reich and Jimmy
Olsen hires groups is that when you just
do this using the standard
classification methods then you actually
do get the difference but then you
notice that practically all the the you
know benchmark classification of
variance methods use the use the human
reference and you know most of the
signal for the variance comes from a
phylogenetic conservations but they
include the the human reference inside
in that generator you divide a huge a
bias because if the if the human
reference just happens to be ancestral
or derived at the particular position is
hugely Kingi as the conservation score
so this is something we had to deal with
and you know I think that could be a
contributing factor so I'd say I'm not I
I wouldn't go so far you know we didn't
look at that in enough detail to say
that you know it's strongly bottlenecks
the populations you won't have some
short-term difference in load say due to
very strongly don't here sir
of alleles for example so there so
that's one thing but I also think that
you know it's a bit tricky to do the I
should I should also know in this in
this context and maybe that's what next
one to say is that is that in David and
Camille actually looked at many more
populations and they also see you know
practically populations which increase
well well just you say not I don't have
a specific opinion about the Denisovans
but but there's no doubt that if you
wait long enough and you have a
demographic difference we take two
populations you will get the difference
due to weakly selected yeah yeah so I'm
saying that's one possibility I mean
yeah it seems to me like with the
bottleneck
if he was growth also the age
distribution of reproduction might
change quadratically and since we
already saw very big differences
associated with mutation rate I'm just
wondering whether you examine to see
that these kind of effects in the same
kind of scenario would you consider the
age distribution of reproduction
how that would that be detectable here
and not so yeah so so one thing I'd say
that to a certain extent we have a
control of the synonymous case here
right because to the extent that these
synonymous differences are neutral then
you know we're just measuring the number
of mutations that happened the longer
lineage leading to one population
compared to another so so I I think that
should yeah so I think that they the
answer as far as I could tell because we
did some simulations along these lines
and some simulations also when we change
the distribution of selection
coefficients and each population and and
and the answer is that you would have to
have so I'd say you'd have to have quite
an extreme effect in order and this is
the important part in order to have any
substantial difference in the number of
them here's alleles carried by
individual than the presence so I'm
saying it couldn't be not to be
detectable yes because for this to
actually have an effect on load you
would have to have a huge effect so it's
not necessarily a problem with our
statistics so much less that it's not
very easy because most of the genetic
variation in at least in some of these
classes comes for things that are just
much older so so when you know
differences along the lineage could
contribute only so much depending for
the time since the split so hope that's
a partial answer